hey guys I'm right right Madison baby we
gonna check out today the trailer for
hell and back yes yes I think I saw a
teaser trailer for this let's see the
official trailer pervasive strong crude
and sexual content hate that kind of
human
punchline coming
a spirits equipped it as an offering
from the Dark Lord Dark Lord queefed it
to another 2min chief oh really our gate
without that portal went to Barnes and
Noble
going down
switch up
oh pretty sure you're gonna die
you guys want to see my digs
during his stay in house a cutback his
self your mama doesn't live here if she
does she was a [ __ ]
check out my skills yo suck it I can
leap in far too the same
I will have a potato klauridsen point
sorry but does saying Pizza torture
alright
oh yeah looks fun looks fun I mean if
you're into like that kind of style of
humor especially like the Robot Chicken
style yeah I could totally see how
that's your kind of film I don't know if
I could watch a full like 80 to 90
minutes of that I honestly like I'm not
huge into they even like cartoon mm-hmm
I feel like we need a red band trailer
yeah because it's said it's rated R for
all this crazy crudeness and stuff and I
haven't seen a movie like that and
that's style of animation that's that
[ __ ] crude they show us a red band
trailer that's showing like here's how
our rated humor this is Dan I might be
on board for it
but right now looks like a movie that's
not meant for kids but won't exactly
appeal to adults like I don't exactly
know like there's a very specific
audience for it that's very small yeah
well you get imaginary we'd really gets
me I mean that's kind of scary
I grew up Catholic I'm not Catholic
anymore but growing up I was really
terrified of the concept of Hell so
anytime I see something like this I get
this instinctual feeling of fear oh no
devil but it's risky
it is a cool concept I mean I like the
idea of two mortals going to hell like
they're not dead yet that's pretty funny
to me I like to like taco bell/pizza hut
being tortured that was the funniest
joke yeah but I want to see like how
inventive a connection that's the thing
is like we saw a lot of dialogue
bantering [ __ ] I would like to see how
much more inventive they could actually
be especially with like their physical
kind of humor there they're set pieces
you know if there's any twists and turns
from like being in hell like that's more
things I wouldn't mind actually checking
out yeah it doesn't look like the
funniest thing on the planet but I think
a red band trailer might make it more
appealing
I gave him an A+ for being inventive
like slightly kind let it is a cool
concept
there was a Robin Williams movie that
did it in a dramatic way that would be
art what dreams may come where he has to
go to hell to rescue his wife Harvey
wanted to see like humans like I feel
like I would enjoy it if it was like a
real-life cartoon yeah Zardo
yeah what kind of animation is this
called again something with clay clay
animation yeah stop claymation
claymation is that it I don't know I
mean they're really cool right now we're
not cool at all
combination no no that was the video
starting videos chill out dude
porn up it's like amateur stuff no you
want to see like nasty stuff xhamster
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to this
chanel if you're new to it subscribe
today and feel like a reject not panning
out and you could check out Madison baby
on the new channel she's launching with
Samantha Ashley felt
whoo you guys know chicks unhatched
exactly how yeah about two chicks on
hatch you gotta see Madison's breasts no
you want to see Matt and follow us on
our social networks Facebook Instagram
Twitter periscope man do you ever vine I
do I'm on all social media yeah we're
all across the board catch Madison also
she with you know she had it a few small
co-starring roles in some small indie
flix you know like The Curious Case of
Benjamin Button the master just started
walking in finding a casino Philip
Seymour
and few other big timers and I heard she
was on her own rejects who medicine baby
yeah she's on Brill rejects the porn
site that's a sad porn site yeah it
offers like fragile enough want follow
us because if we get enough followers we
can get product placement for things
such as in and out I mean do you like
going through the drive-thru yes you
like it when they drive the room in and
out mm-hmm do you like getting double
sandwich you were trying really hard
fresh [ __ ]